des médias américains citant des sources
diplomatiques américains sous conditions
d'anonymat disent que leurs informations
sont que les
Ukrainiens ont engagé une force beaucoup
plus conséquente pour une nouvelle phase
peut-être de leur contre-offensif dans
le sud du pays il parle surtout du front
juste au sud de la ville de Reiki qui
est une ville tenue par les Ukrainiens
dont la région des aporiza les armées
ukrainiennes tentent de prendre les
hauteurs au sud de cette ville ont vu
d'avancer plus vers le sud vers tokmak
qui serait la première ville
actuellement
occupée par les Russes sur la région de
zapporisa qui seraient dans le
collimateur des Ukrainiens tokmakes est
encore une vingtaine de kilomètres au
sud de la ligne de front et reste
occupé c'est dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles que les
Ukrainiens avancent la semaine dernière
j'ai parlé à deux groupes de combattants
engagés pas loin de cette direction et
il parle de champs de mine énormément
danse de artillerie russe qui tire
constamment et ils estimaient que ce
serait très difficile même s'il restait
très déterminé à mener à bien cette
contre-offensive alors c'est
certainement quelque chose qu'il faudra
suivre les développements dont il faudra
suivre les développements dans les jours
qui viennent et cela arrive en même
temps que apparemment une offensive
ukrainienne plus au sud de Velika
nouveau Silka ça c'est plus vers l'est
dans la région de donuts selon des
sources russes pour le moment les
Ukrainiens auraient pris encore un
village au sud de Velika nouveau Silka
dans cette direction là alors des succès
pas très grands mais qu'est-ce que
succès pour les Ukrainiens dont le sud
au même moment où les Russes affichent
des avancées dans le nord-est du pays où
ils essayent d'avancer vers la ville de
Campione une ville reprise par les
Ukrainiens après quelques mois
d'occupation russe l'année dernière et
là a lieu aussi dans le contexte de
frappe à longue distance menée par la
Russie sur toute l'Ukraine hier il y a
eu encore une fois des infrastructures
portuaires dans la région de Odessa qui
ont été touchés et aussi des frappes à
d'autres endroits dans le pays même si
la plupart des missiles ont été abattus
ici par exemple dans la région de
vignitia où je me trouve 5 personnes ont
été blessées par les fragments d'une
requête qui a été abattue et cela a eu
lieu abattu pardon et cela a eu lieu au
même moment où la première dame
d'Ukraine ou les nazelenska est le
premier ministre des schmigal était en
visite justement dans la capitale
régionale Venezia